So Paul, what do you guys do to
actually get out of the way when you're
testing with the user?
What questions do you ask them or what
statements do you give them to make sure
that they're comfortable just
taking the product as it is?
>> Mm-hm.
So by far the most important one is
to make sure that the user knows
that we are not testing them,
we are testing the software.
We will actually often make
that just 100% explicit,
say we are not testing you,
we are testing the program.
If you feel like you're doing
something wrong, you're not,
our program is doing something wrong.
Then we kind of step back and
let them start using the software.
The other thing that we do during
tests which is really important is to
have the user think aloud.
So thinking aloud is a little bit
different than just talking or
just thinking, right?
One of the great, best ways that I've
found to get a user to think aloud, or
to understand what thinking aloud is,
is to ask them how many windows they
have in their house or their apartment,
and most people will say, four?
And you go,
okay, well hang on, walk me through
the process of how you got there.
And the user will go well,
I guess there are two in the kitchen,
then I turn left and there's another
little one there, so that's three, and
then I go upstairs and I guess there's
a couple windows on the staircase.
Okay, that's the process
we want you to go through.
We want to know what you're thinking
as your thinking, what you're noticing,
what you're understanding when you
realize something we want to know that.
And then as the test goes on,
you kind of keep poking them and
keep prompting them.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And if they start to
get frustrated you go back and
remind them again.
This is great information for
us, you're doing nothing wrong.
This is exactly what we want to know,
yep.